تدمير وسد نوبه كخوفك في خرسون الواقع
جنوب اوكرانيا له تداعيات اكبر مما يعتقده
البعض فعاد عن احتماليه تاثيره على امن
الطاقه في البلاد وغمره لقرى عده بالقرب
من السد فان له عواقب بيئيه كبيره صحيفه
واشنطن بوست الامريكيه نقلت عن خبراء
قولهم بان تدمير السد الاوكراني قد يغير
النظم البيئيه الى الابد وان التاثير
الكامل قد يستغرق شهورا او حتى سنوات
لفهمه تدمير السد الرئيسي ومحطه الطاقه
الكهرومائيه قد يؤدي الى تجفيف المنطقه
الزراعيه الغنيه في جنوب اوكرانيا واكتساح
الملوثات في المجاري المائيه وتقلب النظم
البيئيه التي نشات حول الخزان الضخم الذي
تتدفق مياهه الان
ووفق المسؤولين فسيؤدي تسرب مخزون المياه
الضخم من الخزان الى اعاده تشكيل خريطه
اوكرانيا وموانئها وسبل عيشها ما يعرض
المجتمعات التي تعتمد على المياه للشرب
وزراعه المحاصيل للخطر وبالتالي قد يدفع
ذلك الامر بالمزارعين الى التوقف عن العمل
منظمه غير حكوميه اوكرانيه حوالي 100 قريه
وبلده قد تغمرها المياه ومنسوب المياه لن
يبدا في الانخفاض الا بعد خمسه الى سبعه
ايام مستشار رئاسي اوكراني كبير كارثه
بيئيه عالميه تحدث الان وسيتم تدمير النظم
البيئيه ومقتل الاف الحيوانات في الساعه
المقبله وزير البيئه الاوكراني ما لا يقل
عن 150 طنا من النفط تسربت من السد الى
نهر دنيبرو والاضرار البيئيه جراء تدمير
السد نوفاكا قدرت بنحو ثلاثه وخمسين مليون
و 800 الف دولار الامين العام للامم
المتحده انطوني غوتيريش انهيار السد كان
كارثه بيئيه مع تدمير المحاصيل المزروعه
حديثا والفيضانات الهائله رئيسا تنفيذي
لشركه طاقه اوكرانيه من المرجح ان يتم
تصريف خزان كخوفكا الى الصفر وعدد الاسماك
سينخفض تدريجيا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات